et
[Musique]
pour les copains car et s'est passé
c'est le mot oui
faut pas acheter un château comme ça
pour faire des économies
tous les ans il tranche de trappes pour
refait les voûtes du pôle vie on a fait
des matches une aide les gens bages aude
a fait du mâchicoulis de la tour on a
refait tous les coms on y va avec nos
moyens si vous voulez au népal il génère
ni encore moins de milliardaires veille
à aider à faire exploser la renaissance
on est en renaissance française
il ya très forte aspiration italienne
c'est le premier château 100%
renaissance italienne
pour ce qui est des intérieurs
c'est un château qui était très très
novateur l'a vraiment fait école
beaucoup de châteaux se sont aspirés
lurie villandry la gauche tricot les
arches de la rochefoucauld ou été fait
25 ans après
chaque euro et thé club à banquier avant
tout un peu comme affleurantes à c'est
lui qui prêtaient de l'argent au roi
[Musique]
et a pas eu d'entretien pendant 200
emplois très clair là c'est tout ce qui
reste
sauf que les toits se sont effondrés il
reste encore actuellement lié cette
courte il ici et là tour 15e qui était
éventré en 1958 et on essaie
actuellement de préparer comme on dit
les outrages du temps et des hommes
on essayait de refaire toujours tels que
ça pouvait où devait être à la
renaissance
et là vous avez ici une très belle
crédence donc du 16e quant au lit très
honnêtement c'est du bricolage
le but est bien c'est donc pas de tout
refaire mais au moins de cristalliser
pour arrêter le massacre
et tout va bien fin tu vas bien oui nous
devons pousser ce qui lui manque
et bien tout simplement un petit million
de dollars de plus et cérébraux de
vitrages
[Applaudissements]